what I don't understand is how how is it
that on the 2001 nape history exam 52%
of high school seniors chose Nazi
Germany Imperial Japan or fascist Italy
as our ally not the Soviet Union hi I'm
Nick Gillespie with Reason TV I'm here
today with mark Bauerlein author of the
dumbest generation a provocative new
book that says the digital age stupefies
young americans and jeopardizes our
future in fact there's even a second
subtitle which says don't trust anyone
under 30 mark what's the premise of the
book digital culture means means this to
most teenagers it doesn't open them up
to the great big world of ideas and
artworks and and and documents and
politics and Foreign Affairs which is
all out there on the Internet the
potential is there instead it gives them
what teenagers really care about other
teenagers access to one another they're
not going to the Smithsonian Institution
website when Nielsen ratings examine the
most popular websites for young adults
nine out of the top 10 teenagers nine
out of the top ten or four social
networking 55% of high school students
spend less than one hour a week reading
and studying for class they spend nine
hours a week social network and this is
what brought me into this this work
studies of leisure habits by young
adults and one thing we can say is that
the leisure reading people do young
people do the visits to museums that
they do the library visits that they do
those have gone down and that that's
just natural because the menu of leisure
options for young freedom teenagers and
young adults has gotten bigger reading
is has a smaller portion on the menu
that they have and when you go into the
average 15 year-olds bedroom now it's a
all time Media Center yeah there are few
books up there on the shelf there's the
laptop the cell phone video game console
blackberry iPod and all those diversions
give them something a lot more
compelling than the story of Antony and
Cleopatra and Caesar
PBS was running a film festival I never
watch movies but you know I was stuck
with these it was a foreign film
festival and they showed all the
classics of Fellini and Fritz Lang and
and Charlie Chaplin and Orson Welles and
actually mostly foreign films and I just
got into it and and so you know I don't
understand all of this but something
about a lot of these images it just sort
of opened opened my mind a little bit if
I could go back to Maryland today and I
was that age I could always get online
and hang out with my friends or I could
I could get on the cell phone and call
people or go to teen blogs about my high
school and I I could have remained stuck
in in adolescent world and the adult
world seems like on the other side but
don't you feel that it's more likely
that more kids will have an experience
similar to yours because if you're
roaming around on the Internet
it's virtually impossible or even on
Netflix it might be a mistake that you
ordered the wrong movie and suddenly you
get love and taurah where you in that
vignette you talked about the rules of
the game the atrociously overrated
renoir movie right but I mean it just
seems to me that the the possibility of
this stuff being thrown in their path is
probably higher now just because there's
so much more of it out there and
available well III think that with the
big universe of the internet it's an
empowerment tool it lets people go where
they're already interested it it it's
disposed to them and the teen ego is is
a really powerful strong thing
especially the collective team ego and
I'm not sure that if these things do
happen by chance that that they stick
with it that's why the mentors in young
people's lives are sewing and talk a
little bit about that I mean who's to
blame here or what are the forces that
are making this
you know what you're talking about what
are the forces behind that and part of
it certainly is the mentor the
gatekeeper class right I mean these are
you know these are dr. Zaius is from
Planet of the Apes who have lost their
inner faith right you know it's it's
it's something that I think I blame more
than anyone's I blame my colleagues the
humanities professors who passed along a
an ear reverence toward historical
knowledge and literary understanding and
civic understanding they they don't give
students the conviction if you don't
read these books you're not going to be
a complete citizen you're not going to
be a complete individual III think that
too many of them want to be relevant
they don't want to be old fogies and
fuddy-duddies and reactionaries and
retrograde conservatives they worry
about again being on the other side of
their students world and students need
to learn when you're 18 years old your
friends aren't going to make you build
your vocabulary your friends aren't
going to make you respect the Venetian
Republic of the late Renaissance early
Renaissance you you you need to have
someone come into your life and tell you
look that there's a great big world out
there and you've got to pull yourself
out of the little tiny social world that
you're in and mentors or mentors have to
be the ones to do that and I think
students want their teachers to do that
a lot more you know they want their
teachers to rebuke them for their
adolescent diversions
I tell students in class all the time
you guys are lazy and ignorant and don't
tell me how busy you are you always
talking about how busy you are you watch
2 hours and 41 minutes of TV a day and
that those are the latest ratings and
you it's like you're you're the CEO of
General Motors you leave class you flip
open that cell phone to check in and see
what's going on in your in your
important lives or you got to run into
the library and check your your Facebook
page to see what's happening you know
that there is there are more important
things to do
awning inspiration is a good motivation
to vote first for civic activity 1 you
know inspiring politicians come and go
and an inspiration also is it's so much
about you how you feel how this
politician appeals to your needs that
that's not a good basis for citizenship
you need to feel more it's not about
your emotional responses about your
responsibility to guard your
prerogatives you got to look at the
First Amendment real seriously and you
got to regard your leaders not just as
figures of inspiration but also figures
of danger too they are in power and
people in government over time are going
to do what human beings naturally do and
that is sustained their power expand it
and you've got to be a political player
to limit them I want to thank Mark Baer
aligned author of the dumbest generation
for coming and talking to Reason TV for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie